what's up i have read your book i have
found your channel and it's been
life-changing a simple question i would
be asking you is uh i have just gone
through a very rough breakup and uh the
thing is i've become really good friends
with my ex like my ex's friends okay and
her family and i'm trying to detach
myself and they're constantly in touch
with me i want to know a good way of
just
walking away or moving how how hard is
it just to ignore their
like contacts tax phone calls like just
don't answer them
i mean i've never been that kind of a
person so it's a little bit difficult
for me to take this
look look look look when you unplug from
society you know from from the matrix as
it's called you know so to speak
you're you're going to have to adapt and
change which means there's going to be
people that that you're going to leave
behind
if you don't want to stay in touch with
your ex's friends
you're under no obligation to stay in
touch with your ex's friends
just don't respond to their text
messages or just say look you know i'm
i'm super busy i'm not interested in
hanging out
that's it
i mean they were very good friends to me
so it's really difficult for me to just
break
friendships or like okay but you
obviously don't see any value in
remaining friends with them though right
i guess so i guess so okay so if you
don't see any value in it and you want
to let them go then just keep them at
arm's length and you know they'll figure
it out could you elaborate arm's length
what is a healthy arm's length away well
you know i've talked about drawing
perimeters
like i would draw a perimeter around me
and my family okay my siblings my kid my
girlfriend parents you know stuff like
that right like these are the inner
circle then there's the outer circle
i've got my boys let's say in the one
percent community they need something
i'm there they call me i'll pick up
they're at the general's tier right like
they're the big boys
then you know you have these other
perimeters and these other perimeters
sort of thing right so
on the outside of the perimeter like i
have this show and i have guys that call
in in the show that want to ask you know
for my advice and talk to me and i'm
happy to do that because you guys help
me make content and i offer you
something back right so there's these
different layers kind of like the rings
of a tree you know when you cut a tree
down you got those rings sort of thing
right decide where they're going to be
in that series of rings like whatever
that perimeter happens to be is it
closer to you or is it further away from
you and if it's further away from you
and you don't see any value in
maintaining the friendship or the
relationship
then just keep them on the outside you
know it's arm's length you know it's
further away from you
all right thank you thank you thank you
rich you got it hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you